大家好 我是中电数据产业集团的胡承盛
很高兴参加银鱼组织的
数据要素可期流通技术的系列课程
我本次分享的课程是
数据元件安全可期流通的新模式
本次课堂主要是围绕一种标准化的数据出击产品形态
数据元件来展开讲解
主要内容包括形式与要求
数据元件的内含生成原理与突破线作用
数据元件设计生产与流通
数据元件的应用场景与时间安利以及展望
五个部分
那近年来数据与经济社会发展深度融合
各领域对于数据的应用需求持续增强
数据作为新型生产要素的价值预加突显
从宏观层面来看
我国高度重视数据基础设施建设
当的二十届三中全会做出明确指示
要求培育全国一体化数据市场
完善数据要素价格和收益的分配机制
要加强加快推进国家数据基础设施的建设运营
像国内数据产业人工智能等比喻
市值超过百亿美元的数据公司很少
扔在成绩培育
产业数字化发展不均衡的情况仍然存在
有在进一步发挥数据要素的协同优化作用
尤其是像DeepSake大模型
还有巨声智能机器人等的出现和发布
使得企业对于数据的工区的需求进一步扩大
包括权力数字化转型的要求提升
也是显得预加数
行至预加负担
数据开发利用继续加强个人隐私保护和数据安全治理
在行业层面上
其实像一些国家出台数据20条之后
数据产权、数据流通、收益分配、安全治理等基础制度框架
是基本上已经形成有相应的解决框架
在地方像江西、陕西、湖北等全国各省市
都逐步在建立数据局和数据集团
来对数据产业包括数据设施做统筹规划
各地方各行业也在陆陆续续跟数据要素
进行深度的看讨和融合
发挥行业传统
发挥行业在与数据要素深度融合之后的作用
在数据跨境和基础设施方面
国家也在积极做相关的一些探索和布局
在此背景下我们提出了一种新的模式
我们将数据要素的中间态定为数据元件
提出数据元件是对数据资源进行清洗治理
加工生产形成的信息密度大
安全属性强
形态稳定产权清晰
价值释放效率高的数据表现结果
我们看到数据品内有很多
但是它的来源分散在各地
当一个数据运用或者一个场景
在需要很多数据的时候
它获取数据的成本很高
同时数据在使用过程中
它的安全属性很难去保障
在这个基础上
我们通过给予一个安全的生产加工环境
通过规模化的去生产一种
标准化的数据出息产品
来去连接供需两单
从而解决数据供数栏的问题
或安全方面的一些解决
安全方面的一些难题
在这个基础上
我们将数据元件定义
或者是在组织上
是要将它定义成一个
净元信息的一个
净元数据的一个信息载体
或一个基本组织单元
主要的形态包括组态数据元件
模态数据元件和组态数据元件
组态数据元件主要是对数据资源
脱敏处理后
有弱干个相关资段形成的数据级
那模态数据元件主要是由数据资源的
关联资段通过见谋形成的数据特征
这主要是两个常见的一些场景
一种是我们经常面临到一些
写信息它比较敏感
这个时候我们在公布
或者在统计的时候
我们可能就需要对它进行一些
脱敏处理
像公司的名称注册资本
经营时间
我们可以通过一些简单脱敏
一名化或者是一些泛化来处理
来降低它的一些敏感性
那有的我们需要一些企业
或者是一些主体
它的一些具体的一些特征的时候
原始数据难以直接获取
那我们可以对原数据经过一些出加工
比如说像企业它的一些
每年或者每月的一些用水用链的数据
通过对它进行一些加工
形成一些文明性特征
来判断企业是否经营正常
那这个时候我们就需要对原水数据
进行一些建模
形成一些新的特征
来去做相应的一些应用
那这个时候的话
这种类型的话其实就是
典型的一种模型
模态数据元件的应用
除此之外的话
我们还会睡觉一些组合态数据元件
那它主要是由组态和模态数据元件
组合形成的一些数据
或者是数据特征
那这种的话
其实就是逆用于
它具需要有一些原始数据的一些信息
我们可以对它做一些简单托运
同时也需要
有一些变换之后的一些特征
这时候进行一些组合
形成的一个数据级
或者是一组数据特征
那我们叫做左派数据元件
那我们可以发现
就是数据元件
它在生产过程中的话
它其实非常注重它的安全
还有它的一些价值和品质方面的一些特性
那在安全数据方面的话
我们主要是通过对原始数据的关联资段
进行组合加工实现信息剥率
通过数据可不可见
数据不动程序动
使得原始数据在应用过程
不直接就向应用单实现风险隔离
所以我们可以
我们在设计过程中
数据元件的加工生产环境和使用环境
它是两个隔离的环境
从而能够做到风险隔离
那在价值属性方面的话
数据元件是一个进一元信息载体
是标准化的数据出击产品
是计量和计价的基本单元
是交易的标的物
能够有效提升和
能够有效提升数据价值密度
从实现数据资源的产品化流通
和规模化应用
那在品质方面
数据元件
我们会经过一系列的质检
包括对它使用的数据资源
元件开发的模型
还有元件的结果进行
一致性检测
包括完整性 准确性
及时性 规范性等等
那尽可能完整的覆盖
所包含对象的静态出现和动态活动
然后我们通过统一标识
统一接口
然后内容一致性的检测等等
来去确保数据元件的规范可用
我们发现2024年底的话
其实国家就联合多部委
印发了国家数据基础设施建设指引
其中明确指出
六大数据流通
利用设施的技术路线
包括了数据元件 可信空间
可信数据空间 数场 数连网
区块链 银丝保护计算平台等等
那数据元件的话
其实就作为了国家明确指出的
六大基础路线之一
现在目前在北京 郑州 温州等
首批市民城市已经开展的落地实施
中国电子联合清华大学
构建的基于数据元件的数据基础设施
工程方案
以数据安全与数据要素化
工程基础细极为基础
重点建设了数据金库 数据元件加工交易中心
数据要素互联网 安全可信
数据空间等数据基础设施
为这个数据流通利用提供的安全可信环境
下面主要是介绍数据元件的生成原理
数据元件是通过脱敏处理
或建模形成的数据特征
是从海量多样动态的原始数据中
通过抽象表中和信息过滤
形成形态稳定 高价值密度的数据组织单元
数据元件是数据要素化质疑的信息载体
我们可以看到
就是从原始的海量的数据资源中
我们可以被它进行选择
选择一批数据资源
然后通过一些原件模型
开发成数据元件
这些数据元件的话
可以是通用型的数据元件
也可以是一些定向
指定的一些指定需求的数据元件
结合这个场景来去构建
从而能够更方便的服务
更多的业务场景
在这个工庄的话
就是我们还会涉及到
数据元件的一些封装
它主要是包括两个方面
一个方面是从产品角度
我们要对它进行产品化的封装
另外在流通过程中
我们为了去寻找 寻止 解析
我们还会对它进行一个数字对象化的封装
数据元件产品封装的话
主要是包括它的一些元件结果
编码 产品封装码
包括产品溯源码
以及产品收费信息
数字对象封装的话
其实主要是将数据元件作为数字
来进行封装和管理
这里面主要是包括它的一些标识
就是在互联网上
它的一个对象标识
还有元数据以及数据元件实体
我们通过这两层封装之后
数据元件在统一的数据要素
互联网上
可以通过数字向标识
实现全网的互联互通
数据元件的话
它带来了几个方面的突破性作用
一个是能够解决数据确权难题
但我们基于数据元件的三次分离
三阶段确权
其实能够将复杂的数据产权体系
简单化 清晰化
反而推动实现数据的三权分制落力
我们知道原始的数据的话
它可能比较混乱
它的产权的话
它可能分数到不同的个人
或者是组织
我们通过对原始数据加工程数据元件之后
那这个数据元件
它的数据运营主体和元件开发主体
就获得了数据加工程权
和数据产品的经营权
在这个基础上的话
它的权术就很清晰的进行了一项分割
然后我们在使用元件的过程中的话
或者是数据元件在流通之后
它的产品经营权
就由数据产品的开发经营主体来获得
这样的话
它的产权的话
通过三杞大分离就变得清晰可见
可追溯
那在数据流通过程中的话
其实面临的问题
主要是安全的存散
那在此基础上
我们也是通过构建的这种数据金库
包括它数教数不连网
来去促进数据元件规模化的生产
和产品化的流通
从而充分释放数据产品的价值
同时我们也在综合考虑数据元件
它的一些体量
质量
信息量等不同因素
来构建数据元件的一些估值定价模型
为数据产品定价
提供一些科学依据
那我们通过构建以数据元件为核心的
一互两往的安全治理架构
实现了对数据要素的全生命周期的
一个安全管控
从而有效的隔离数据风险
那经过多年的这个试点实践
数据元件其实是已经形成了系统的设计
包括生产和流通技术体系
在标准体系方面的话
中国电子联合清华大学构建的
数据安全以数据要素化
工程标准体系
根据国家省市相关法律法规
制定的数据资源 数据元件
数据流通交易 安全合规
物质定价等系列标准规范
为数据要素市场化改革提供的
统一规范指引
其中数据元件的标准
主要是包含了元件的结构要求
设计开发规范 安全审核规范
和质量规范等四个方面
我们在数据元件的设计过程中的话
我们提出了场景分析法
数源分析法和元件分析法
其中场景分析法
主要是通过分析客户的实际需求
输离可支撑其业务模型的元件清单
举个例子
比如说在金融领域场景
主要是包含了一些受信
封空 货客等具体的业务应用
还有像保险领域的话
它主要是包含一些核验
还有定价等等
在这个过程中的话
我们确定完场景的话
我们就需要了解
它可能会应用到哪些数据
我们可以通过确定数据应用产品功能
包括应用业务模型和紫模型
来分析它的模型架构
输离形成可直接输入
给这些模型的一个基础元件清单
数据数源分析法
主要是从数据产品 数据本身来出发
根据数据的原始特性
来进行元件功能的设计
比如说原数据
它可以用于哪些场景
它可以做哪些事
我们可以按照数据持有主体
包括业务预域
还有细化数据项来做相关的一些分析
同时我们需要对数据的一些重要性
和敏感度进行一些评估
有些场景可以用到哪些级别的数据
有些场景的话
那可能作为公用数据
那它可能需要进行一些这个泛化透明等等
那在这过程中
我们需要对它元件的功能进行设计
输出匹配数源实际情况的一些
这个基础元件清单
那在前面两个事情做完之后的话
我们通过对场景分析
和数据分析形成的两个
基础元件清单进行比对分析
这个时候的话
主要是要做两个事情
一个是鱼对齐
另外一个是颗粒度对齐
那鱼对齐是要求我们要确保这个数源测元件
和应用测元件在鱼层面保持一致
同时我们也需要元件的这个类型
包括它指导的这个时间空间的颗粒度
是统一一致的
这个时候我们就能够形成我们
公虚双方都符合的
一些这个中间的这个标准化的这个
数据级或者是数据特征
那在整个工程体系里面
其实我们围绕数据元件的这个加工的话
我们是总结出了一套标准化的流程工序
那其中就包含了数据汇聚这里
数据元件加工 数据元件检测
数据元件流通 数据元件使用等五个阶段
围绕这五个阶段的话
我们建立了涵盖15个步骤
40道工序的数据治理工业流程
并依托这个数据金库和数据元件加工交易中心等
成道装备 实现了数据要素
高效 级约 安全和规模化流通利用
那具体在这个工业流程里面
首先我们看一下数据汇聚治理阶段的话
其实它主要是完成的资源化
我们通过对元数据进行入库 清洗 建餐
整个流程的话
我们相当于实现了数据的前期的一些治理工作
和保障前期数据它的一些安全进化
就是有些可能会有带着一些病毒
或者是有一些数据不完整等等
我们前期会对它做些处理之间的工作
那有了这个数据治愿之后
我们就需要有一个安全的
可靠的一个加工环境和开发的相关的人员
那这个时候的话
就主要是包括了元件开发商的一些入住
然后元件开发商对元件进行一些规格的设计
同时在这个安全的环境里面
怎么去进行模型的开发 调优 中视
入库 调度生产等等
那整个里面它会设计到
就是后台提供的一个安全可靠的环境
对它的这个计算环境进行保障
同时对它的一些资源的一些调配
进行这个前方位的一些管理
那元件生产完之后
它还需要经过进一步的检测
才能流通到这个要素市场
那检测的话我们主要是从武大方面去检测
包括它的标准 包括安全 合规 质检
还有故事定价等等方面
来对它进行上市前的准备
那元件标准方面的话
其实主要是针对它的一些秘名 编码 类型
还有原数据 自然数 基督数等进行这个检测
质量方面的话
那我们除了对原始数据
还会对它的一个元件模型
还有这个模型元件的结果等等
来进行这个质量检测
来对它进行相应的一些评估
安全审核方面的话
我们会对它的这个三个阶段
比如它的这个资源 资源获取阶段
包括它的原件模型加工阶段
还有这个结果进行三届审核
同时我们会对它的这个相关
就是元件结果
跟原数据它的一些相关性
相思性的做相应的一些不肯定审查
防止原数据直接出去了
那在有些情况下的话
我们还会对它的敏感信息
包括它的一些元件结果进行相应的一些分析
同而适配不同的这个应用场景
那核归方面的话
主要是做相应的一些这个
确诠授权的一些这个检测
是否包含主体
然后主体内容行为是否合规等等
那做完这些检测之后
其实主要就是数据元件
资产化的一个过程
怎么去做封装
怎么去做产品化
怎么去估值定价
怎么去吸权登记交易等等
这个我们也是在系统里面
有成套的一套这个工序流程
来完成相应的工作
最后的话我们在使用过程的话
我们是要将数据元件作为一个数字项
形成一个数字
唯一的这个全网维的一个标识
同而能够在这个数据购买网上去注册
检索解析调用
同时我们将数据元件
能够作为一种基本单元
能够对它进行计量计费
然后和多方的一个分账等等
活动
那数据元件它其实
前面说它如何加工
包括流通
那在使用过程中它还睡着
怎么去安全的传输
那在这里面我们主要是引入
这个数连网的一个技术框架
将数据元件做一种数字项
对数据元件数字项进行存储
封装协议管理和使用
并采用了数字项标准协议
它里面包含的接口协议和解析协议
来实现对数据元件的一个标识
注册解析寻职和访问
形成了一套数据元件封装
数据元件按需搜索
数据元件存证上限的要索互通的一个网络
也就是我们这里面提到
数教书互联网
那它体系性的解决了
数据元件互联互通中的数据安全
和跨域大规模流通的难题
提高了数据元件流通中的
这个互通性安全性和可信度
那目前数据元件的话
主要是在安全可信数据空间
高涨数据等方面实现了一些初步的应用
其中在安全可信数据空间方面
那我们知道传统可信数据空间的话
主要是通过了数字合约
包括多方计定的那些规则
还有数据使用控制等等技术
来去实现这个数据的安全共享
那我们在此技术上还加了一层
就是我们原始数据
在进到这个空间之前的话
我们会把它加工成安全可控的数据元件
那我们在加工过程中
包括的加工后会对它进行一些安全审核
从而进一步提升数据
就是数据在这个流通过程上
它的一些这个安全性
那我们基于原始就可用不可见
数据元件使用可控可提良的这种应用模式
可以链接上下由多方主体
为行业提供数据安全融合共享
和可行流通的这个新型数设施和解决方案
那在高质量数据级方面的话
主要是基于数据元件
构建大模型的语调库以及智能体应用
它有一个好处就是说
原始大模型的话
它可能不管治理没治理
它的质量好坏
不管都一股烙的进去
但是有个问题就是说
你数据质量越好
对于模型训练的效果
它就会提升有很大的提升
但是如果数据不好
那可能会对模型它的一些分析性
推理性造成很大的影响
那我们通过数据元件
就是将原数据通过治理
标准化加工各种方面的一些安全检测
形成了标准化的这种数据级
从而能够大幅的减轻治理负担
包括模型的训练的负担度
也会大大的降低
除此之外的话
我们还可以基于数据元件构建语调库
用来辅助大模型的一些评测
根据用户对大模型评测的一些需求
可以结合评测语调库完成训练
微调大模型考卷
实现大模型能力综合评定
客观准确的提供对模型能力
参数了一些这个横向对比
我们数据元件的话
其实已经联合各个高校
包括各个产业已经发展了将近五年了
那我们在此技术上是形成的
制度技术市场三维一体的
这个塑胶策划共产发案
目前是已经在德阳大理
郑州徐州温州等地完成了
这个试验实验工作
那北京目前是正在这个快速推进中
像德阳市集资产交易平台的话
已经是上架了数据元件三圈一个
数据元件销售合同
经文已经突破了一个亿
完成全国首个基于数据元件的
质页融资500万元的一个货币
那像在郑州的话
郑州主要是运营这个中国
郑州数据金户开展的这个
数据元件的国家试点
那数据金户的话
目前是已经接入了59亿条的这个数据
已经累计签约了
42亿数据元件交易合同
引入了22家这个生态企业
同时接待部委地方政府等385批词
已经形成了较大的一个规模了
在行业级应用方面的话
其实主要是包括一些这个金融服务啊
医疗健康 龙岩电力
现在龙岩等重点领域
那像在中部地区某银行
针对于这个个人信贷业务
已经推出基于数据元件的一些一代场景
主要是以数据元件方式
能够提供稳定的贷款评估
数据产品和服务
有效的去解决这个金融场景
下面的一些这个信用欺诈呀
包括评计之后啊
信息核验等问题
累计服务了10万亿客户
其实在这个基础上的话
我们其实主要是会涉及到
一些这个基础数据的获取
包括这个贷款人信息
这主体授权书的一些授权范围
查询客户的婚姻啊
学历啊 医保缴税信息
那我们知道这信息
对于个人来说是比较敏感的
那在这个基础上
我们可以通过对他们进行一些这个
模特的加工
做相应的一些稳定
状态的一些这个特征变换
形成相应的这个数据元件
来服务这些应用
从而降低这个数据泄露的风险
或者滥用的风险
那还有像医疗方面的话
浙江某医疗健康服务企业的话
推出的是这个安整无优项目
以数据元件的方式提供了
这个用户健康评估
或这个个性化的这个健康方案
累计服务了将5万亿这个客户
并获得了这个浙江数据开放
创新应用大赛的这个总结赛的
二能奖
那在这个里面的话
他其实主要是通过获取这个
就是在这个进到这个用户性授权之后
能够拿这个用户的基因信息
包括运动数据
心理评估等多维度健康数据
来去对个人的这个身体
潜在的一些这个健康情况进行一些分析
那这里面的这个数据的话
他其实也是会收到一个
很多这个敏感信息
那如何对他进行这个安全加工
包括怎么去安全应用
提出相应的一些挑战
那在这个用户我们也是通过
举数据远见和这个工程理论
来去做相应的一些方案解决
那展望未来的话
我们觉得认为啊
就是数据远见
包括隐私安全计算
数据空间
数连网 数场等技术路线
有基融合
形成
一个整体是一个必然的趋势
那数据远见在这里面
也将发挥这个重要作用
为数字经济领域
高质量发展
助于一个新的动能
那数据远见将在保护国家数据安全
和个人隐私
贡献国际数据跨流
跨进流动创新方案
处理人工智能发展
购注数据要素
流动互联网
释放数据资产价值经济发展
等方面发挥重要作用
红尚
目前的话就是
尤其是在数据安全方面
很多原始数据不让出狱
包括
行业的一些重要数据
还有一些个人隐私数据
那我们有了数据远见之后
就能够很好的对他进行相应的
一些这个标准化处理
怎么去脱敏
然后怎么去授权
要有哪些合规的一些这个
手续
然后需要在什么样的这个安全环境面
可以去做相应的应用等等
那在跨境方面的话
我们其实
构建了高效安全的一些
这个数据跨
跨境流通体系
包括构建了前沿先进的这个数据
跨境技术给做
在这个绿色反保方面的话
我们通过
对脏数据
或者对原数据的一些这个
呃提炼处理行程
标准化的高信息价值密度的
这个数据远见
从而能够降低这个
大规模的这个数据处理
的复杂度
然后提高这个大模型的应用性能
降低超大模型的数据处理的消耗
那在这个数据流通方面的话
我们其实数据远见
成为构住数据测量网的一个重要支撑
它可以通过数据远见的这种标识
能够快速的去解析定位
同时通过
呃构住的这个安全的这个屏障
来保障原始数据不出誉
但是又能够更好的服务这个UVM
同时数据远见标准化之后
也能够更好对它去进行吸权
那包括资产化处理定价等等
那
其实我想表达的就是说
数据远见
它在整个的这个数据要素上中
它发挥的这个价值不仅仅是说
它是一个
初级的这个数据产品
而说
它在整个的生态里面
能够带动更多的这个
呃
数据生态或者说体验
参与到这个数据要素适量化的过程中
能够更大
更快的去发挥这个数据要素的这个价值
那以上是本次课程讲解的主要内容
期待和大家一起新化探讨
完成认知
谢谢大家